so some of you have been wanting me to  address something i guess i could talk  about it on the podcast you know how  twitter is they'll they'll pull up  anything in your past basically what  happened is i was arrested for it's  super random armed robbery and vehicular  manslaughter so i'd love it if we just i  mean i'm addressing it of course but i'd  love it if we just move on i don't  expect to hold everyone accountable for  their you know stupid things they did  two weeks ago  at moments like these one must take  stock of their actions and their effects  on the world on saturday june 15th i  posted on a tuesday instead of the prior  monday like my banner promised  i apologize to everyone who sees me as a  guiding light and a positive influence  in their lives and i promise that from  here on out  i will only be posting hits  classics and bangers